Speaker 1: Now I want to talk about something
else that is is very, very important because
in light of. The concerns about
future authoritarianism saying,
Hey, you know what? In an authoritarian
us, you would start to see, for example,
the Trumpist will get lighter sentences or
better treatment from the judicial system.
This is already sort of happening, and I'm going
to give you guys some very specific examples.
There's this context we've seen about the Trump
rioters now, more than 700 of them who have been
charged that they're being treated so unfairly
that they're being held in bad conditions,
in jail, in prison, pretrial detention, all
of these different things. And we actually now
have an investigation as to the sentences for
these individuals. And it turns out that two
thirds of the sentences for the Trump rioters are
milder than what the prosecution has recommended.
Judges are getting the recommendation. And they're
saying, I'm going to give them a lighter sentence
in two thirds of the times now. If you look at
individual sentences, you'll see right wingers
saying four years for this, five years for that.
That's crazy. They're being treated poorly because
they're Trumpists. But let's look at the actual
data. Judges have declined US proposed sentences
in two thirds of the January 6th cases so far
this. This is among those who have been sentenced
when federal judges The Washington Post.
When federal judges in Washington began
hearing guilty pleas from some of the hundreds
of riot participants from the riots. Some were
highly critical of prosecutors for pursuing only
misdemeanor charges and not just seeking jail time
for many defendants. Is it the government's view
that the members of the mob that engaged in the
Capitol attack were simply trespassers? Asked
District Judge Beryl Howell incredulously in
October. Is general deterrence going to be served
by letting rioters who broke into the Capitol
overran police resolve liability through petty
offense pleas? But for all four defendants,
how will sentenced? She has imposed less jail time
than prosecutors sought, saying that government
plea deals in most misdemeanor cases are forcing
judges to choose whether short jail terms or years
of probation pose a stronger deterrent. Her
decisions are not unusual. The article goes on
to say federal judges in D.C. have gone below the
government recommendation in 49 of 74 sentencings
held for the rioters in the years since
the attack. That's about two thirds of the
cases. Most have not yet been sentenced, so we're
looking at the ones that have in eight cases where
prosecutors asked for jail time. The judges opted
for probation. Of the 74 people sentenced so far,
35 have been given jail or prison time,
14 home detention and 25 probation alone.
There is a sort of infographic here that you
can look at, and we'll link to this, which shows
up in pink those who got lighter sentences
than the recommended in yellow. Those who got
harsher. And that applies to look like a couple
and those who got exactly what was recommended.
It is untrue. It is untrue that the Trump writers
are being treated unfairly harshly. Now we're
going to get to some of these other aspects later,
which include, you know, Republicans saying, Well,
it's just terrible how they're being held in
pretrial detention. They can't build a good
defense if that's what you do. Yes. People like me
have been saying for decades pretrial detention,
which is disproportionately something for people
that can't afford bail. In some case, sometimes
it's because you can't afford bail. Sometimes
it's not granted. Different situations we've been
saying that needs to be reformed for a really,
really long time. The right never cared. Now they
care because it's Trumpists, those same right
wingers saying these people are being treated
like terrorists. Now some say they are terrorists,
but the conditions in these jails are terrible.
One guy didn't even get the vegan food that
he asked for. We've been talking about jail
and prison conditions in the United States for
decades. They didn't care. They used to say, Well,
if you're there, you're there for a reason and
you don't deserve to be in a Norwegian hotel or,
you know, whatever analogy they like to make.
Now they care because it's their people. So let's
look at the facts. Two thirds getting lighter
sentences than what was recommended. Make sure
you're following me on Twitter at De Pacman.
Remember that tomorrow, Tuesday, January 11th,
6:00 p.m. Eastern, we will be doing the first
David Pakman Show Chess Tournament of the year.
Make sure you join our chess club. It's free. This
is totally free. David Pakman dot com slash chess
and then you can play in the tournament tomorrow.
I hope to see you then. Welcome back, everybody,
remember that the David Pakman show is primarily
funded by viewers and listeners through the
membership program, that's particularly true
for the next 90 days as we have been banned
from all monetization on Facebook. Why? Because
an algorithm misinterpreted a pro-vaccine video
that we posted as anti-vaccine. I'll have more
information about that tomorrow. But needless
to say, we could really use your support at join
Packman dot com. You'll get access to the Daily
Bonus Show. It's an extra show every day for our
members when you sign up at join Packman dot com